we're looking for a
apartment or a home to shoot
a music video this is something you
would let us do
you would let us do it we're shooting a
video from mr harris
harry's house just got a brand new
meaning as the singer crashes a few
lucky fans brooklyn pack to film his
latest music video it's not something
you expect to happen when you open the
door
after work on a tuesday we were just
like discussing our work day sitting
around in our living room we did not we
did not think that was gonna happen for
harry's latest appearance on the late
late show with james corden the tv host
puts his directing hat on to film a
music video for harry's new song
daylight now we have no locations we
don't know what we're doing we don't
know where we're shooting it but we're
going to give it our best try i've never
directed a music video before are you
trusting me with this
yeah
yeah it turns out the ladies who live
there isabelle caroline hadley and
sydney are some of harry's biggest fans
like big big fans you are like a crazy
psychopath because yeah
there's
harry harry styles is all over is this
harry styles as harry potter are you
joking
so one direction
right we need to hide all of this
because i'm worried you're a psychopath
i think it can't be anything worse
than that okay
and get this when et caught up with the
lucky gals sydney revealed harry
eventually saw all her collectibles he
saw it and he said it was okay he felt
comfortable being around me so that
meant a lot to me after 10 years of
waiting to meet him that he was okay
with my level of fandom i'm sure he
seemed crazier not long after that
moment james went into full director
mode and let's just say harry he's a
trooper and here's the mood all right
it's the end of the night okay so pop
your top off and we'll then we'll start
seeing it okay
just take the top off
can i keep my jump on
it's up to you saying you've got an
album to sell
i can't stress this enough this was all
james's idea and all of this cut up into
confetti okay we can't have too much
confetti i was in a christopher nolan
movie
now this is my dressing room and the
ladies didn't just land their apartment
they got to be in it too okay girls can
i get the girl girls come on in come on
in coming in okay
one two three go everyone laughing and
harry nothing nothing at all okay now
hadley four go four four that's it
that's it that's it
should we just scrap it is it too late
to just do a carpool karaoke
and sure it's an unconventional way to
film a video but the final product does
not disappoint
[Music]
and for the ladies it was an experience
of a lifetime all i wanted my whole life
was just to meet him just for one second
just you know just take a selfie just
meet him walk away this was beyond my
wildest dreams and it's really a dream
come true but not even a drink because
you wouldn't dream something so amazing
yeah the next morning waking up it like
still felt like it was a dream yeah we
couldn't sleep that night we didn't yeah
we were skipping down the street in the
morning yeah going to work the next
morning it's like how are we going to
think about anything else for the rest
of our lives
[Music]
you